Right down the Democratic Party.
You don't have any candidate for president who's making reform,
uh,
even an important issue,
let alone a primary issue.
Um,
and of course we had a president who was elected under the drain,
the swamp slogan,
but of course nobody believes he has any plan or any intent to do anything to
drain that swamp.
Yeah.
I'm hoping that having him in office is such a,
that the whole thing was such a cluster fuck and that so many people are so
disturbed that it's going to make people more politically active and more aware
of the consequences of having someone like that in office.
Yeah.
And actually weirdly unifying.
Because even though the Democrats are not doing this right now,
which is really depressing to me,
you know,
we have these things that we know we disagree about and we like fueled the
politics of hate as we kind of yell at each other about these things.
But there's a set of issues that we all agree about and the,
and the most important set of issues we all agree about is the deeply corrupted
nature of this government.
And there was a poll done by a university of Maryland in the middle of 2016
asking about anger and frustration with government found the highest level of
frustration in the history of polling.
And then when they asked the reasons why they were so angry and so disaffected
with their government,
the reasons people gave her all the same things,
like the influence of money,
the influence of lobbyists,
the parties care more about corporations and about,
and then then we broke them down about how to Republicans think about this and
how to Democrats think about this.
There was no statistical difference between Republicans and Democrats.
You know,
sometimes the Democrats were more concerned,
sometimes the Republicans and the levels we're at like 80 and 90% so literally
84% of Americans would say it is big money.
That is corrupting the way our Congress functions,
right?
So here is common ground.
And what was so extraordinary about the 2016 election is watch a Republican
candidate stand on a debate stage.
You know,
in September of 2015 Donald Trump stood on a debate stage and pointed to every
one of those.
Kennedy's and said,
I own all of you.
I've given all of you money and I know the way the system works and the system
is corrupt.
And he called Super Pacs and abomination and he attacked the idea of money in
politics.
And so what that signaled is that Republicans too could be rallied to this cause
of addressing this deeply corrupted political system.
If only we could find the candidates who would do it.
And I think what Donald Trump has done is teed up this moment where we can step
back and say,
look,
we disagree about a lot of things,
whether it's GMO or climate change,
whether it's healthcare for all or college for all,
whatever.
We disagree about a loving,
we got to work a lot of things out.
But here is something we all agree about and we should be smart enough to
realize if we don't fix this,
the nine of the things we're arguing about matter.
You know,
you can't,
it's not serious to stand on a debate stage and say you,
you support single payer health care without also saying,
but first we're going to fix this corrupted system because there's no way to get
single payer health care in a world where doctors and pharmaceutical companies
and insurance companies are funding elections.
You can't say you're going to get climate change legislation in America without
addressing the corrupting influence of money in politics because the oil camp
that the dirty energy industry has an enormous opportunity to block this change
through the way we fund campaigns.
So this is a moment where we should be able to get everybody in this political
system to step back and say,
Hey,
wait,
the system's broken.
We can see as broken.
The first thing we have to do is to fix the broken congress.
And if we fix that Congress,
then we have a chance to have an argument about what policy makes sense for
America.
And we each have our views,
but no views are different.
But the thing we don't agree about,
we should be able to agree on.